(foreboding music)
- Okay. Greetings, everyone.
One of the things you learn
when you become a historian
is that most of the great quotations
that people cite were never
actually said by the person.
So, and the internet
has only made this worse
because the internet filters
for what sounds right,
and what sounds right is very difficult
from what a specific person actually said
at the specific time.
So, if you track down, like
the 100 most quoted things,
especially by people
like Einstein in general,
they didn't ever actually
say those things.
Somebody said they said those
things, it sounded right.
So the example I'm thinking of,
I don't think Stalin ever actually said
that a million lives is a statistic,
and one life is a tragedy,
or a million deaths is a
statistic, one death's a tragedy.
He's quoted to that effect all the time,
but I have never actually seen the source
where Stalin says that,
the primary source,
and this is by the way,
this is how historians work,
is that we are always working our way back
towards the primary sources
and then building our
way back up to stories.
So if I, like everything
that I tell you here
is the product of,
almost everything is the product
of somebody else's research at some time
in some archive,
finding things out, making new arguments,
working it into a book, right?
So the things that,
the things that I'm trying
to present to you here
is general arguments,
are the result of the work of
an awful lot of historians,
generally Ukrainian historians.
And then we try to make it all make sense
in a big class.
But the reason I'm thinking about this
is the difficulty of the subject today.
So our subject today is
the death by starvation,
or malnutrition,
or hunger-related disease
of about 4 million people
in the Soviet Republic of Ukraine
between the middle of
1932 and the end of 1933.
One of the worst manmade
famines in modern history,
at least,
and a turning point in
history of the Soviet Union.
But it's inherently hard to think about.
It's,
even the number 4 million
is hard to think about.
But then also,
unless you've had very specific
kinds of life experiences,
the idea of one person starving to death
is also very difficult
to think about, right?
And so the combination of
those things, 1 million person,
one person starving to
death, but 4 million times,
4 million different people.
So it's a very hard
reality to try to imbibe,
but I'm not asking you to imbibe
it now, as I speak to you,
you know, just for a couple of minutes,
I'm just trying to give you a sense that
there are certain kinds of subjects that,
you know, as humanists,
we don't just blur over.
As scientists, we go
to the primary sources,
and we check those quotations,
and we work our way up to arguments.
But as humanists, we have to
be attentive to human life
and the meaning of human life
and the way that human life ends.
And this is largely a lecture about
how human life ends.
I'm gonna begin it with
an authentic quotation
from the period, from January of 1933.
I'll tell you where it came
from a little bit later.
The quotation is,
"There are villages in
which a significant part
of the adult population
has left for the towns
to seek money and bread,
leaving the children alone to their fate.
In many villages, the
tremendous majority of kholkoz,'
that's collective farm workers,
"and their families are starving.
And among them are many
who are sick and swollen
as a result of hunger.
And a series of cases
no help is given them
since there are no reserves whatsoever.
in connection with this,
many people die every day."
So that is not from,
a letter from a Ukrainian
to a family member abroad.
It's not from a Ukrainian
talking to another Ukrainian in Ukraine.
It's actually from a report,
it's a handwritten note
appended to a report
to the head of the
secret police in Ukraine.
The authorities in Ukraine knew
exactly what was happening.
They were there watching it,
they were there carrying it out,
they were there talking about it,
reporting on it to one another.
It's a handwritten
appendage to the report,
because it's not essential.
The lives of the people concerned,
the deaths are not really essential.
It's not important to the
overall five-year plan
collectivization, the Soviet project.
It's just noted, so it will be known.
Which leads me to the first point
that I want you to understand,
which I'm sure many of you do,
it's that famines are political.
Very rarely do you confront a situation
where a famine is a direct result
of a physical lack of food.
It's the result of a political
decision about distribution,
which is based upon priorities,
where the priority of
preserving human life
may be very low,
or as in this case, it
may not exist at all.
It may not be a priority.
And so, if famines are political,
then you know, that opens one's eyes
to the possibility of how
famines can be created
in the present or in the future, right?
So if, for example, a country
invades another country
and blockades its ports
and says that food will
not pass from these ports
out into the rest of the world,
that is not a lack of food, right?
It's not that Ukraine right
now isn't growing food,
it's that a political
decision has been made
to try to block the export of that food.
And therefore, in the
Sahel, or in Ethiopia,
or in Lebanon, there
might be food shortages
as a result of political decisions, okay.
So,
from the point of view of the Soviets,
the decision to have people
starve in Soviet Ukraine,
we see it as political, right?
From their point of view,
what they think is that
everything should be yielding to politics.
So this is, I mean,
I'm gonna get into the
details, and the backdrop,
and all the arguments about this,
but there are a few fundamental
things to understand
about the way Soviet
leaders understood the world
in the early 1930s that are crucial here.
One is the Leninist idea that
everything yields to politics.
That an elite party, a
small group of people
with the right ideas
can push history forward
in the right direction.
That there's a natural direction
that history is moving,
it's moving towards socialism,
it's moving toward the
domination of the proletariat,
and the right people can push it forward.
And as they push it forward,
everything else has to
yield because we know
that this is the correct
way that history has to go.
Within this worldview,
it's very important to
see that the individuals
who actually exist in the
world do not have any value.
So, you know, you might have been exposed
to some sort of human rights framework
or civil rights framework,
or you might think that
that's natural, right?
All these things are
historically contingent,
and we learn them or unlearn them,
take them in or not,
in this way of seeing the world,
an any individual, any
particular individual,
doesn't really matter.
Because what matters is,
where we're all going to get together.
Not necessarily us even,
but some future generation.
At some point, humanity is
going to be restored to itself.
Alienation's gonna come to an end,
private property is gonna come to an end,
that's everything, right?
That is everything.
The goal is everything.
And means are generally justified.
And this has,
this has another implication for truth,
which is really important when
we talk about this famine.
So this famine is one of
the blunter bigger truths
of the 20th century in European history,
but nevertheless, extremely controversial,
at least for decades,
and one of the reasons for that,
is that the people who carried it out,
had a specific idea about truth.
And their specific idea about truth
is that just as these
individuals don't matter,
also the facts as such, don't matter.
They matter selectively
insofar as they can
help a narrative, right?
That's what facts are for.
But facts as such are not so interesting.
And the narrative has a shape,
and it's the shape of history
that I've described before,
which is that there's a revolution,
the revolution is going to bring,
eventually going to
bring about human harmony
and solidarity.
That overall shape is what matters.
And if it so happens that
millions of people die
along the way,
those individual facts are less important
than the overall shape.
In fact, if we have to,
if those individual
facts amount to something
that we can't ignore,
which is what happened in 1932 and 1933,
the scale of the famine was so great,
it couldn't really be ignored,
then you have to argue that
this was necessary, right?
So at the Congress of Victors,
the Party Congress of 1934,
the argument that was made
to great success and fanfare,
was that the famine in Ukraine
was part of breaking the back
of the international Bourgeoisie
by way of its Polish agents,
and its Ukrainian nationalists,
that the very,
all of the pain and suffering
actually demonstrates
that the revolution has been successful.
And that's a form of argument,
which I'm sure is not
entirely unknown to you.
The idea that precisely
because there was pain,
it was therefore,
it was therefore worth it,
but on a grand scale.
And then related to this,
again, before we get into the details,
one has to remember that
if you are a Bolshevik
in the 1920s and 1930s,
you are taking for granted
that whole groups of people
who exist on the earth
will soon not exist anyway.
So, you know, you shouldn't
be caring about individuals,
you should be caring about
the future proletariat.
But in caring about
the future proletariat,
you have to understand that the peasants,
for example, are going to cease to exist.
That's just the way history works.
And so if they cease to
exist a few years earlier
or a few years later, that's
not your fault, right?
It doesn't really mean anything,
whether they cease to exist
at one point or another.
So it, so this is, I mean,
it's hard to get these things across now
because, you know, there
are some capitalists
who have this kind of confidence
about the way the world works,
but there's nobody on the left anymore
who has this kind of confidence
about how the way the world works,
so it's hard to sort of think
your way back into this,
but if you are sure that
the world works this way,
and has to work this way
and should work this way,
then the conclusion that, you know,
yes, the peasantry is
doomed, I know it's doomed.
Science says it's doomed.
This is the way history has to work,
then you're going to look differently
upon the deaths of millions of peasants
than you would otherwise,
because that group was
doomed anyway, as you see it.
It's not you, you're not
exercising the agency,
history was gonna move in this direction,
You know, you're just playing your part.
So those are just, those are
general things to keep in mind.
The second thing that I wanna
get across is the background
of the 1920s.
So one way to think about the famine
is the way that I've just given you,
you know, let's see the
world a little bit the way
a Bolshevik leader might see it.
Taking a step downwards,
a little bit less abstract,
another way to see the
famine is as a contrast
from the 1920s to the 1930s.
So the Soviets, after
the revolution of 1917,
were trying to do something in the 1920s,
which didn't quite work
out the way they expected.
And that leads to harsh
repressive policies in the 1930s.
Or,
in the 1920s, the Soviets
were taking a kind of pause
from a revolution,
which they always knew
they had to carry out,
by the end of the 1920s,
they knew that they had to carry it out.
And that revolution,
the economic part of the revolution
is what brought collectivization,
the end of private
agriculture, and famine.
So I want you to think now
about this kind of contrast
between the 1920s and the 1930s.
The trick to the Bolshevik
revolution in 1917,
as I mentioned to you before,
is that it was never meant
to be a Russian revolution.
It only became a Russian
revolution in retrospect
after it failed to be a world revolution.
And that sets up the tension,
which is inside this revolution,
and indeed inside this state,
from the very beginning.
It was, the idea was,
we are going to set off
the powder keg in Russia,
the rest of the world will join in,
and then the rest of the
world will help us take care
of the rest of the revolution.
Because let's face it,
the political part is
the easiest part, right?
Transforming the political
system, overthrowing a regime,
is easier under almost any circumstances
than transforming an entire economy.
It involves fewer people,
you can take advantage of
war, and so on, and so forth.
So you have a world
revolution, which doesn't help,
which doesn't happen.
And you have then the need
for socialism in one country.
So how do you build
socialism in one country
to take the slogan?
How do you,
now that there's not a world revolution,
how do you carry out your own blueprint
on the scale of the Soviet Union?
So there are a few parts to this.
One part of this is you
barricade yourself off
from the rest of the world.
So the Soviet Union, as
of the Treaty of Riga,
is is a state with borders,
and as we're gonna see over
the course of this lecture,
these borders will become stronger,
and stronger, and stronger,
one way to do this is to
not let the outside in,
not let the bourgeois world corrupt you,
not let in all the spies and the wreckers.
The second thing that you do is that,
you take advantage of the
scale of your own country.
So the Soviet Union was not,
you know, the Azore Islands,
it was not, you know,
the Soviet Union covered,
you know, a sixth of the earth,
the Soviet Union was the
largest country on the planet.
And so when you look at the Soviet Union,
you can say, well, some
of these places are,
will be like the colonial periphery,
and some, it'll be more like
the Metropolitan Center.
That's not the way they usually
talked about themselves,
I should caution you,
because that's the capitalist
way of talking about things.
But Stalin occasionally did forget himself
and say things like,
What we have to do is carry out a policy
of internal colonization.
The French and the British, says Stalin,
have far-flung maritime colonies
that they can exploit,
we don't have that, but we
do have all of this landmass.
And so we can exploit parts of it
to industrialize other parts of it.
So you don't have the whole world anymore,
but you do have a very big country
with more and less developed parts,
and you can exploit the
less developed parts.
And then the third thing that you can do
is that you can make a play for time.
So the play for time is the 1920s.
The play for time is
the New Economic Policy,
the trick of which in Ukraine,
to make it very, you know,
to simplify a little bit,
is that Ukrainian peasants
get to keep the land
they took from Polish landlords, right?
That was their revolution.
Where Ukrainian peasants get to keep land
that somehow they ended up
with after the revolution.
The revolution didn't
make that happen directly,
like, no Bolshevik in
Petersburg made that happen,
but it happened.
And they get to keep the land now.
And of course, they're pleased with that.
The second way you buy time
is the national question.
You're aware that there
is a Ukrainian nation,
as I think I've said before,
this kind of odd difference
between the 1920s and the 2020s,
is even the Bolsheviks,
I mean, even the most, you know,
radical, ruthless,
doctrine error internationalist,
of the early 1920s,
like, they were aware that
there was some Ukraine there
that they had to somehow deal with,
they disagreed with how they're gonna,
but they were aware that it was there.
And then weirdly, 100 years on,
when Ukraine is much more clearly there,
it's existence is denied.
But so you try to buy time
with the national question.
And this was not, I mean,
this is an interesting policy,
and it didn't happen just in Ukraine.
I mean, around the Soviet
Union, it was called like,
"Korenizatsiya," like rooting,
in Ukraine, It was usually
called, "Ukrainizatsiya,"
"Ukrainizing."
The idea was,
yeah, maybe the nations are hostile to us,
or they don't know,
or they don't see the benefit.
But what we will do is we will give them
a kind of capitalist stage of development.
We're giving the peasant a
capitalist stage of development,
we're gonna let them keep
the land, they'll like that.
We're gonna give the
nationally-minded elites
a capitalist stage of development,
because we're gonna give
them university education,
we're gonna give them
jobs in the bureaucracy.
They're gonna have social advancement,
you know, they're gonna
move from the countryside
into the cities, right?
Ukrainian writer, Valerian Pidmohylny
wrote a whole novel about this.
So, we're gonna give them
the capitalist stage of
development, basically.
'Cause remember, the whole scheme here
is that the Soviet Union
has to find its way
on its own to socialism.
So this has a kind of coherence.
So in the 1920s, inside Soviet Ukraine,
you have affirmative action for Ukrainians
as against Russians and Jews, chiefly,
the Ukrainians moving
in from the countryside
to the cities up, up through the ranks,
and then you also have
a very sophisticated,
very interesting movement
in Ukrainian culture.
Just to name one person, if I
can name, I'll just name one,
which is, Mykola Khvylovy, who
was from the Kharkiv region.
Again, remember, like in general,
the Ukrainian nation comes from the east,
that's kind of the default.
He comes from Kharkiv, the Kharkiv region,
a little town, Trostyanets, I think.
In the Kharkiv region.
I should never say like, "I
think," in front of the camera,
'cause now like there will
be a million Ukrainians,
did Khvylovy become from a
place called Trostyanets or not?
And is one of my TFs,
checking that online right now
as we speak, perhaps, yes.
So I can be corrected in real time.
Anyway, but the point about Khvylovy
is that he was a wonderful writer,
he was in charge of a series
of literary organizations
who carried out, or was
in the center of something
called the Literary Discussion,
which was about what is the orientation
of Ukrainian literature gonna be?
World literature, European literature,
Western literature,
Khvylovy's big thing for which he later,
as you can imagine, got
in trouble was that,
it shouldn't have a colonial relationship
to Russian literature, right?
It should be a literature on its own.
The second major figure of this period,
whose name is on your sheet,
is Mykola Skrypnyk,
who was a fairly orthodox
Bolshevik in most respects,
but who took the Ukrainian
question more seriously.
He was the commissar for
education from 1927 to 1929.
He was from Bakhmut, which is,
you might have heard that name,
just because it's where
there's a lot of engagement
between Ukrainian army
and Russian mercenaries
from Wagner right now,
that's where a big part of the front is,
in Donetsk, Bakhmut.
So in the 1920s, there was a play for time
with the national question,
and the idea was, if we
make our version of Ukraine,
that will bring people into the system,
and they will be loyal,
and then also it will
make Ukraine attractive
to those Ukrainians in Poland,
who you remember from the last lecture,
those five or 6 million
people who had reasons
to be often disenchanted
with Poland. Okay?
The problem with this play for time
is that this play for time
had to come to an end.
And it had to come to an
end as the Bolshevik saw it,
in a certain way,
which was with the
collectivization of agriculture.
You know, it's, again,
it's hard to get yourself
into this mindset
because I realize the way
that we see things a
century later is different.
But,
if you really think that history's on it,
actually, it's not so different.
Like there are a lot of people after,
I mean, this is a kind of loose analogy,
but just stay with me for a second.
There are a lot of people after 1989
who thought that absolutely, for sure,
capitalism was gonna lead to democracy.
Like, 100%, we know it,
Like, that's the way it's gonna work.
That's a little, that's
of course, not true.
I mean, as an empirical
matter, just not true.
It's been a great century for capitalism,
but not so much for democracy.
If you've, you know,
like I'm talking about
like your lifetimes,
or since you got out of
kindergarten, basically.
Since you got outta kindergarten,
democracy has been going down.
Coincidence? I ask you, right?
(students laugh)
So that, like, but if you've
ever been in that groove
where people say that
like, a certain kind of economics
has to lead to a certain kind of politics.
That will help you see what they thought,
which is that,
there was one form of
capitalist development
and they had to get through
it at an accelerated rate.
And so, and they could
not imagine any other way
to do that besides extracting
from the countryside,
and building up in the cities,
building the factories,
building the mines.
And the way to do that was
to collectivize agriculture
as they saw it.
Again, they couldn't think
of any other way to do it.
And by the way, like these
things which seem inevitable,
although they're not,
I mean, you could have gotten,
Ukrainian agriculture would've
been much more profitable
had it never been
collectivized, obviously,
they could have taxed probably,
and made more money from it.
But, you know, the things which,
things seem inevitable and happened
because people think they're
inevitable then become models.
So just a little excursus here,
the whole Chinese
Revolution does not happen
in the form that it happens
without the Soviet Revolution,
And that the whole idea
that you have to collectivize agriculture
as a form of development,
that wouldn't have happened in China
without the Soviet model.
And likewise, without the famine
that we're talking about here,
there wouldn't have been a similar famine,
although on a much greater scale in China,
a couple of decades later on.
Okay, close excursus.
So,
the only argument at the
top of the Soviet state was,
at what time to do this, and how quickly.
And this is a very interesting juncture
because in the second half of the 1920s,
after Lenin is dead,
and Stalin and others
are jockeying for power,
Stalin shows the intimate relationship
between bureaucratic politics
and theories of everything, right?
Because what,
we don't have this anymore,
we just have bureaucratic politics,
we don't have theories
of everything, right?
That's why everything seems so blah.
But so when Stalin is arguing,
what he says is,
"You know, these comrades,
these comrades are saying that, you know,
that collectivization
should happen too soon.
And these colleagues or
these comrades are saying
it should happen too late, right?
And I'm right in the middle,
I've got it just right."
And so this is an argument about
who is the best scientist of history
because it has to be done
in exactly the right way.
But in fact, what he's doing is,
he's getting rid of some rivals,
and then getting rid of some other rivals,
defining himself as being in the middle,
which is, that is how this
kind of politics works.
The party is supposed
to represent history.
So okay, here,
the sequence would be,
there's history, which
brings you the proletariat,
and the proletariat brings you the party,
and the party brings you
the central committee,
and the central committee
brings you the politburo.
And then the politburo is then dominated
by one individual or occasionally
a small group, right?
And so the who gets to
be that one individual
is then determined by these,
like, who is the best
at these kinds of games,
which was Stalin.
But the way you make the argument is,
we're talking all,
and you believe it
probably to some degree.
You're talking about the whole
development of human history,
and who is right about how
to advance human history.
Those are the terms in
which the argument is made.
So Stalin on the argument
of collectivization,
manages to consolidate power.
And this is very important because,
and there's nothing solely about this,
this is just normal politics,
normal tyrannical politics.
Once you're attached to a
policy that is disastrous,
what do you do? Right?
You don't say it's disastrous,
you say, actually it's the
triumph of human history
and civilization, and so on, and so forth.
It had to be this bad.
So the fact that this is
Stalin's signature policy
is very important.
This is the policy on which
he rides to the top position
in the Soviet,
in the party, and therefore
in the Soviet state.
But collectivization as
such, doesn't go very well.
They start off slowly in '28, '29,
in early 1930, they race
forward in a couple months,
in early 19, in early, sorry, early 1930,
they collectivize,
at least according to
their own statistics,
about half the country.
And that led to, as we saw before,
a lot of resistance.
In Ukraine, you had a
million acts of resistance
recorded in this period,
you had whole villages walking
towards the Polish border,
trying to leave,
a lot of resistance,
including armed resistance
and attacks on party members.
As we saw before,
it's in March where Stalin gives this
"Dizzy With Success" speech,
it's in March of 30 when the Red Army
is placed in full battle readiness
on the western front for
fear of a Polish attack.
But there is no Polish attack, right?
There is no Polish attack,
as we saw last time,
the Poles react to the
five-year plan by saying,
"Wow, the Soviets state is
stronger than we thought."
When the Soviets propose
peace talks, they accept,
there's a draft of the treaty
between Poland and the Soviet
Union in August of 1931,
the treaty is signed in July of 1932.
I mention this again because
it's gonna be important
for how the famine is discussed.
And so now I'm gonna
let you in on a secret
about how totalitarians do things.
it's really smart to talk about threats,
which you have already resolved, right?
You don't talk about a threat
which is actually a threat,
because a threat which
is actually a threat
is a problem for you,
which you don't wanna have
out there in the world.
But talking about threats
that you've just resolved
is very helpful because they're
under your control already,
and so they only exist discursively.
So that's stuff that we talked
about in the last lecture,
The Volhynia Experiment,
the spies going across the borders,
that was all very real.
But by the end of 1931,
latest early 1932,
that had all been taken care of,
those people had gently been arrested.
The Soviets were running more
spies in the other direction,
they were not afraid of Poland,
they signed a peace treaty.
That was pretty much done for,
I mention all of this because
when the famine comes,
what is Stalin going to blame it on?
He's not gonna blame it
on a real threat, right?
You don't talk about real threats
because real threats are
actually out of your control.
You talk about fake threats,
or you talk about threats
that you've already mastered
because then they become,
at least you think ,purely
under your control.
Although, and this is now not a trick,
but a reality of totalitarian systems,
but not only.
Once you inject a very big
lie into the system like that,
like for example,
that the Polish nationalists
and the Polish spies
are ultimately behind the famine,
once you get that into the system,
and people live and die on that lie,
that lie can then take on
a life of its own, right?
As we're gonna get to by the end.
Okay, so how does the famine happen?
Partly, the famine happens
because of expectations.
1930 was a very good crop,
the requisitions targets for the next year
were therefore set very high.
And 1931 agricultural conditions, weather,
was all worse,
and most of the farms have
by then been collectivized,
and collective agriculture
just doesn't work
as well as private agriculture,
especially in the transition year,
when you're doing it for the first time.
So the famine begins in late '31
as the peasants refused
to surrender grain.
Local party activists in Ukraine,
completely, truthfully report up the ranks
that there is famine, there are shortages,
they ask that requisitions targets be,
so requisition is when you
take grain away, right?
They ask that the requisitions
targets be decreased.
At this point,
the crucial thing is
interpretation, right?
And here we get to a big
irony about these systems,
which is that they end up
relying on personal explanations.
So the irony of that is that supposedly,
Marxism-Leninism is a science, right?
It's a science of society,
a science of history.
But then if something doesn't go your way,
doesn't go the way you predicted,
who do you have to blame?
You can't blame yourself, you
can't really blame science,
you can't blame the method
because that would call
Marxism into question,
and therefore, your legitimacy.
So you have to somehow imagine
that particular individuals
have almost superhuman powers.
And this happens over
and over and over again,
those categories that I
mentioned half-ironically earlier
of like the spy and the wrecker,
certain individuals turn
out to have, you know,
in order to explain these things,
extraordinary, extraordinary power.
You might catch this in
things that seem like
conspiracy theories, right?
Or the notion,
you know, that people are
crossing borders, right?
Or that one or two spies inside the party
can make a whole system.
You see this there examples all over,
but in the show trials later on,
when like people would confess
to doing a whole range
of impossible things
that you have to be a super-villain to do,
to be both a Nazi and a
Zionist at the same time.
You know, these,
and then, or you know, when Khrushchev
says that the whole problem
with the Stalin period
was Stalin himself.
Like even that's not true, right?
Even Stalin is not responsible
for all the problems of
the Stalin period, right?
And so the way the system
deals with things going wrong
is actually, ironically,
to give superpowers to evil individuals
and to call them names, and so on.
So I'm pressing that point home
because this is the way
that Stalin handles in 1932,
the famine in 1932.
He says that like it's
somebody's fault, right?
So it starts with,
it's the Ukrainian party's fault,
they've gotta work harder.
They're not going out
there to get the food,
but it's the fault of the
individuals in the party.
Stalin says they have to be held,
I'm quoting from July 1932,
"Personally responsible."
So this is, you know, this
is detached from reality.
They're doing the best they can,
but they're an impossible situation.
He then moves from there to the reason why
these individuals in Ukraine
are not doing what they should do.
And the reason why they're
not doing what they should do
is Poland.
It's that they're corrupted
by Ukrainian nationalists,
and Ukrainian nationalists
are in turn running,
you know, they're being
run from the Polish state,
and actually, Pilsudski
is in the back of it,
you know, with his
hands on the marionettes
running everything.
Which, you know,
in "Sketches From A Secret War,"
I make the point, this would've
been news to Pilsudski,
because at this time,
the Poles were not really
able to do anything
that they wanted to do in Soviet Ukraine,
and they were appalled and confused
by the spectacle of the
starvation that they saw
in 1932 and 1933,
In August of '32, Stalin
writes an important letter
to his,
to one of the two other important members
in the politburo, Molotov and Kaganovich,
Stalin referred to them
as "Our ruling group."
He wrote to Kaganovich,
his trusted collaborator,
and the great thing about
this period, by the way,
is that people still wrote letters.
So,
alright, I won't,
I don't have time to wax nostalgic
about the 1930s and the typewriters,
but Stalin wrote to Kaganovich,
"The chief thing now is Ukraine.
Things in Ukraine are terrible,
it's terrible in the party,
they say that in two Ukrainian Oblast,
I believe, Kyiv and Dnipropetrovsk,
that around 50 Raikom may have spoken out
against the grain requisitions plans
considering unrealistic.
In other Raikom,"
meaning, local regional party commissions.
"It appears situation's no
better, what's this like?
It's not a party, but a parliament,
a caricature of a parliament.
It's terrible in the Soviet organs,
Chubar is not a leader,
It's terrible in the GPU," secret police.
"And Redens is not leading,
is not up to leading the
fight with counterrevolution
in such a large and unique
republic as Ukraine,
If we don't make an effort now to improve
the situation in Ukraine,
we may lose Ukraine.
Keep in mind that Pilsudki
is not daydreaming,
and his agents in Ukraine
are many times stronger
than Redens or Kosior think,
keep in mind that
Ukrainian Communist party,
500,000 members, haha,
even includes a few, yes, not a few,
not a few rotten elements,
conscious and non-conscious Petlurites
as well as direct agents of Pilsudski.
As soon as things get worse,
these elements will not be slow
in opening a front within
and without the party,
against the party."
So this is Stalin's
personalist interpretation.
It's Ukrainian party members,
so it's not the laws of history,
and of course it's not him,
it's not the policy of collectivization,
it is that these guys are deliberately
sabotaging the harvest in
order to break Ukraine off
from the Soviet Union.
Now, this interpretation is very important
because it's not,
I mean, it's not,
it's not everyday reality
which drives policies, right?
It's, and this is true in any system,
it's the elite interpretation
that's going to drive policies.
And in a system like this one
where there is no, like,
there's no not much
feedback to the politburo,
the feedback to the politburo
would've been local
party secretaries, right?
And that feedback has been cut off
because Stalin says we can't trust them.
They're precisely the people
who didn't take responsibility.
They're the ones who're the
agents of Pilsudski, right?
We can't trust them.
So now there's no way,
there's no informational feedback
to the top of the system.
This interpretation is
what's going to drive policy.
And the policy, I broke
this up into seven,
It's on the other side of your notes.
There are seven specific
policies which I think,
clearly authorize us to characterize this
as a political famine.
Seven particular things that happen
in just a few weeks in
late 1932 and early 1933,
which mean that rather than
a few hundred thousand people dying,
which was at this point,
like in late fall of
'32, is still possible,
4 million people die.
Again, these are political choices
about what to do with available food.
During this time, the
Soviets had food reserves,
during this time, the
Soviets were exporting food,
they were exporting food
from ports in Soviet Ukraine
at this time.
People could have been fed
from the food that was,
it's not that there was a lack of food,
it's a decision about how
you treat particular people.
So this cluster of policies,
it's kind of extraordinary
condensation of things
that happen from the end of November 1932
to the end of January 1933.
At the first is the
return of grain advances,
this meant that,
if you had met your grain
requisitions targets that year,
you were then given some grain back
to live on and to plant for the next year.
In November of 32, this was reverse,
which meant that suddenly,
everybody was vulnerable.
But also, you have to think about
what this means in practice,
which is a hard thing to convey.
The famine is being carried out by,
by local party members,
local state officials, policemen,
enthusiastic university
students coming back,
people who believed in the revolution,
coming back to their villages,
sometimes their very own villages,
it's being carried out by people.
The food is being physically
taken away by people.
So every one of these
measures, or most of them,
it involves people rushing to the village,
rushing to a collective farm
with the authorization
to take things away,
and in practice, this often
just meant taking everything.
Right? Just taking everything.
Second measure is the meat penalty.
it's 20 November,
if you didn't make the quota,
then you had to pay your tax in meat.
And so if any of you have
any kind of rural background,
do you understand what that means?
Like, if you are living on a farm,
the goat or the cow is
the kind of last resort,
so you'll slaughter that goat
or you'll slaughter
that cow if you have to,
but in the meantime,
you're gonna take the
milk, but if you have to,
you have that meat that might
get you through the winter.
Everyone, so all of
these collective farms,
villages that couldn't make the quotas
then had to turn in their goats,
or their cows.
Just to quote a peasant girl
from "Bloodlands," who says,
"Whoever had a cow didn't starve." Right?
It's a kind of basic,
but then they lost
their cows in late 1932.
Third specific policy, the
blacklists of 28 November,
according to the blacklist,
if you hadn't met your target,
then you had to surrender
15 times as much grain,
which of course is impossible,
and was a complete
authorization of all the party
and state forces to come and take
literally whatever was there.
The blacklists also meant
that you were cut off
from the rest of the Soviet economy,
so it was illegal for you to exchange
in any kind of way with any part
of the rest of the Soviet economy.
Number four is maybe the most diffuse,
but it's incredibly important.
It's the national
interpretation of the famine.
And this has to do with this
character of Vsevolod Balyts'kyi,
who was the head of the
state police in Ukraine
at this time.
And at this time, later it was different,
but this time, quite close to Stalin
and had personal conversations
with Stalin about all this.
He comes back to Ukraine
in December with a message,
that Ukrainization has been
carried out in the wrong way,
right?
Ukrainization has been carried
out on in the wrong way,
Ukrainization has
promoted the wrong people,
Ukrainization has been dangerous,
and there are a bunch of,
so there are a bunch of
details involved with this.
Like party commissions now
come from outside of Ukraine
to run the party.
Stalin sends in about a hundred
of his own trusted people
from the outside to run the party.
But the gist of it is that,
now, if you are in favor of Ukrainization,
you're in danger,
but also if you're not being enthusiastic
about requisitioning the grain,
you'll be called a Ukrainian nationalist,
and then you'll be sent
to a concentration camp.
Or perhaps worse, right?
So this whole, a right-wing nationalist
deviation is being defined.
And the method which every party member
would've understood was,
if you don't go through with
requisitioning the grain,
even in these conditions,
you will yourself be punished personally,
and you will likely be sent
to a concentration camp.
That was a standard punishment.
And you know, this.
and then with this, with
the whole plot that like,
also the Ukrainian communists are informed
that many of them are in
fact, secretly Polish agents,
there's the Ukrainian
military organization,
which is run by the Polish
the Ukrainian military
organization doesn't exist.
The Polish military organization
hasn't existenced since 1921,
but Balyts'kyi, who was a
very creative individual,
explained the existence
of all of these groups.
So right around,
so that's December-January '32, '33,
at this point, about 1
million people are dead.
But this interpretation,
which says the you and the
party will be punished.
That's one of the big things,
which turns it from 1
million into about 4 million.
Fifth measure, 20 December, 1932
is the affirmation of
the existing grain quota.
So they could have reduced the quota,
nothing in the scheme of things,
that wouldn't have meant anything
except that fewer
Ukrainians would've died.
Maybe they would've exported
a little bit less grain.
They could have reduced
the quota, they didn't,
they forced it upon the protesting
Ukrainian party leadership
in late December 1932.
Number six, January of '33,
the peasants were banned
from going to the cities.
This is an unusual situation.
In general in a famine, or in any, like,
let's say there's a food
shortage caused by bad weather.
You wanna be in the countryside, right?
It's always better in those situations,
almost always,
to be a farmer than it
is to be in the city.
But this famine was different
because the state had taken total control
over the countryside and
had been very successful
in extracting food from the countryside,
so you actually had this unusual situation
where peasants were fleeing
to cities to beg for food.
Or peasants, and this
happened over and over again.
Peasants would send their
children to the cities to beg,
to beg for food.
Thinking that that was the only chance
their children had of surviving.
So as of the middle of January,
peasants were banned from doing this.
And then at the end of
January, 22nd January,
the Ukrainian Republic of the Soviet Union
was separated from its
neighbors, Belarus and Russia,
it became illegal to leave
the Ukrainian Republic.
So again, a natural response to hunger
is to go somewhere else.
This blocking, the internal
board of the Soviet Union,
made this impossible.
It also clarifies to what extent
this is a specifically
Ukrainian event, by the way.
The fact that Ukrainians knew
that if they went north
to Belarus or to Russia,
they'd be more likely to be fed.
And it has the same kind of irony
as begging in the cities does, by the way,
because Ukraine produces food for Belarus,
it produces food for Russia.
But Ukrainians in this situation,
were going to Ukraine,
were going to Belarus and to Russia.
So by the summer of 1933,
and again, we don't have time,
you know, and maybe there are words,
it'd be very difficult to
describe what this means.
But by the summer of 1933,
we're at about 3 million
inhabitants of Soviet Ukraine dead.
In addition to this, the
Ukrainian party itself,
the Ukrainian party has been purged.
About 120,000 people are forced
out of the Ukrainian party.
and particular focus is on the people
who had carried out the
Ukrainization policies of the 1920s.
Mykola Khvylovy commits suicide
on the 13th of May 1933
after learning of the arrest,
he was this very important writer,
the one who led the Literary Discussion.
After he learned of the
arrest of one of his friends,
another writer, he committed suicide.
He would certainly have
been killed otherwise,
he was not wrong to believe that.
The Ukrainian writers were taken
to a specific concentration
camp in Karelia,
where a number of them
were later executed.
There's a term for this,
which is the "Executed Renaissance,"
captures the phenomenon very nicely
'cause there was a renaissance.
The 1920s really were a renaissance.
It was the most interesting
decade in Ukrainian culture,
at least until 1914,
at least until 2014,
to the present, which is
also very interesting.
But the 1920s were
extraordinarily productive
in basically all fields of culture.
And then almost everybody who was,
not almost everybody,
most of the people involved were executed.
Okay, and then a few weeks
later, Mykola Skrypnyk,
the guy who had been the
commissar for education
is himself accused the national deviation
and also commits suicide.
So those two suicides
are symbolic of, you know,
the end of the 1920s,
the end of this idea that
Ukraine could somehow
move forward into a communist future.
The postscript to this,
as I wanted to suggest
at the very beginning,
is the Great Terror.
So the Great Terror is a
separate chapter in "Bloodlands,"
and you'll read about it.
But there are a couple of
odd ways in which the Terror,
the mass shootings and
deportations of 1937, 1938,
are actually kind of an
afterword to the famine.
Or they're another example
of this principle that,
especially in conditions
of extreme tyranny,
you will find yourself doubling down
on the terrible policies that you made
rather than altering them,
rather than, you know,
rather than taking some
kind of responsibility.
I mean, you could say, I mean,
from an ethical point of view,
one of the most interesting things about
this kind of ideology is that
it allows you never to have
to take responsibility, right?
The word responsibility never appears
or to put in the converse way,
when people in the sixties
and seventies begin to,
in the communist world,
say interesting things
in opposition to communism,
the the moral vocabulary
which they draw from
is centered around the
word responsibility.
Which I mean, if you just
sort of flip that around,
you can see one of the attractions
of being on the inside of this, right?
That you don't have to
take responsibility.
Okay.
So the Terror.
In two ways, the Terror is
connected to the famine.
The first is that the five-year plan
includes in February 1930,
the idea of "de-kulakization."
So a "Kulak" is a more prosperous peasant,
or somebody whose neighbor
says he's more prosperous,
and de-kulakization means
a kind of artificial
class conflict in the countryside
where the middle peasants
and the poorer peasants
are supposed to denounce
the better off peasants,
and then the better off peasants are sent
to this emerging system
of concentration camps
in the Soviet periphery,
which we know is the gulag.
So as a result of de-kulakization
beginning the 1930,
a lot of peasants,
the disproportionate Ukrainian peasants
were sent thousands of
kilometers away to Siberia,
to camps, for five-year terms.
Where,
Stalin gets the idea,
they were vulnerable to being recruited
by Japanese military intelligence.
Not quite as crazy as it seems,
Japanese military intelligence
was actually quite active and skillful,
and they were thinking
about the national question
inside the Soviet Union.
So it's not pulled from nowhere, right?
I mean, the thing about all of these ideas
behind the Terror is that they're not,
they're never pulled from nowhere,
they just take some element of reality
and exaggerate it to
grotesque proportions.
But so the idea was these peasants
are serving five year terms,
they're gonna be coming back
to the Western Soviet Union,
and they may cause trouble, right?
1931,
so 1935, 36, 37.
This is one of the origins
of the peasant action,
which is the major action
in the Great Terror.
So when you think of the Great Terror,
if you think about it at all,
you might be thinking
of the intellectuals,
and the show trials of the party members.
That was about 60,000.
The Great Terror was about 700,000 people.
The biggest group affected
by the Great Terror
were actually the peasants,
and the suspicion of the peasants
goes back to collectivization.
Or, you know, if you
like, the notion that,
"We did something drastic
and terrible to them,
maybe it wouldn't be so surprising
if at some point they might
wanna do something to us."
That's the fundamental logic.
The second set of major
actions in the Terror
are the national actions.
Again, the details are
all in "Bloodlands."
And the most important
of the national actions,
the bloodiest one,
which more than 100,000
people are executed,
which is a big number.
Is the Polish action.
And the roots of the Polish
action go back to the famine.
Because the explanation that
was given for the famine was,
there's the Polish state,
there are Polish espionage,
the Poles have recruited
the Ukrainian communists,
that's why they're carrying
out all this sabotage.
That is not true in anything
like social reality,
but it remains true inside
the Soviet apparatus
of repression.
That story, if I can torture you,
that's not how I want to put it,
if people are tortured
on a very large scale,
according to a scheme in which the idea
is to get them to repeat a certain story,
like, "When were you recruited
by Poland?" And so on.
then those documents become part
of the internal bureaucratic reality
of the apparatus of repression.
And then the Polish, or the Polish plot,
although it didn't
really exist in reality,
only gets bigger in the
internal bureaucratic reality
of the apparatus of repression.
To the point that this fellow Balyts'kyi,
who I mentioned earlier,
the guy who made it up in
the first place, right?
The creative intelligence
chief who made it up,
he was then caught himself
according to this logic.
"If the Polish penetration of
Ukraine and the Soviet Union
was so incredibly
important, comrade Balyts'kyi,
why weren't you onto it earlier?
Perhaps that's because you yourself
are a Polish spy, right?"
So the person who invented this idea
was himself executed as a Polish spy.
But that's just a,
that's an individual example
of a much larger phenomenon,
which is that in the national actions,
roughly 100,000 people will be killed
as being a spy, as spies for Poland.
And this, although it's a
horrifying event in its own right,
in some sense also goes
back to this original
set of collectivization.
But it's the suspicion of Poland,
the story of Poland, and the inability
of the regime to admit mistakes,
take responsibility,
and the way that a big
lie then metastasizes
and remains inside a system,
all of that lead us towards these events
in the Great Terror.
Okay, Thank you very much.
(calm music)